Michelle Pfeiffer said that she loved
working on Maleficent so much because it
made her feel safe having so many women
there and she really really liked that
how was your experience and do you kind
of concur with what she said well her
scenes were mostly with me and else in
that in that strength yes I do but I
also you know Sam's amazing and true
tells amazing so I is that there's a big
family there l said she wasn't things
she's most proud of is like the
evolution of your all's relationship on
and off screen and that's really been
very important to her and special to her
when we were talking to the Eternals
cast everybody just felt like a
collective sigh of relief that you guys
can finally talk about this movie that
you can say stepa matter we can see you
all I mean I'm not so sure what we can
say did they know because Marvel I still
think we're still seeing each other
behind the screen wait did you did you
hear dude I didn't know KITT was in the
film did you just find that out today
yeah on stage Marvel the whole thing I'm
thrilled but I had no idea playing a
superhero push you up a little bit makes
you feel a little bit more in power it
does but it's a little you know what it
is though you get the outfit on and
you're feeling really like you know and
then you see your kids and you're like
you know and then the way they look at
you like what are you doing you know
then you get nicely brought back down to
earth like you are so weird
speaking of your tribe you have such a
tight-knit tribe taking Maddox and send
him off to college is everybody kind of
like walking around in a daze missing
him it was - what was very beautiful so
everybody say goodbye and when it was
time for him to you know take him to the
airport and some jumped in the car to
take him and everybody was a bit every
but everybody just when you know that
your kids love each other and you see
the way they all without any kind of
prompting or pushing give each other
notes hug each other take care of each
other support each other
then you feel like they're gonna be okay
and they're gonna always have each other
so that just kind of gave me goose bumps
because the way you put your family
together I think is a lesson for all of
us on how to just really let seriously
on how to just love you know and have
you stopped crying yet did you have the
ugly cry can't imagine Angelina having a
good but did you have the ugly cry can
Barris your children ugly cry I'm more
dude like I just I also just at some
point at the big glasses and I can any
who's like the amount times I turned and
waved it was like I dunno is the one
moment my life I think I turned around
six times before like the airport just
kind of you know to just you know and he
sweetly stayed and kept waving knowing
that I was going to keep turning her and
you could feel that he he knew he
couldn't you know what he was feeling
that to somebody because I tried to be
cool when my mom dropped me off but
inside I was the only remembers so he
was feeling that - he's pretty it's nice
to know that he knows how much he's
loved he'll be back soon enough
like I haven't already set my plane
thank you
you